-Right now, we're about
to go head-to-head
in the first-ever "Tonight Show"
Stand-Up Battle.
Now, here's how this works.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is the Stand-Up Generator,
and we'll each take turns
hitting this button right here,
which will randomly select the
name of a short stand-up routine
written by you, Jerry Seinfeld.
-This is some of my stuff. Yeah.
-Yes, and we'll perform it
as best as we can.
-Now, you know
this is all set up.
This is not real.
[ Laughter ]
No, it's real. It's real.
No, they are going
to decide, right?
-Yes, they're
going to decide, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cowbell clinks ]
We'll perform it as best we can.
At the end, we'll decide
once and for all who is
the better Jerry Seinfeld,
me or Jerry Seinfeld.
-Jerry,
since you wrote all these bits,
why don't you go first?
We'll start the generator.
-All right, start the generator.
-Yeah, here we go.
-Wow.
-You press the thing
when you're ready to go.
-Hey. Those are really
my bits on there.
-Those are your bits.
-"Wait up."
All right. Now, this bit
is called "Wait Up."
It's on cue cards.
Do you remember the bit?
-I do. I remember this one.
This is actually part
of a Halloween routine.
This is a good bit.
-Okay.
-You're going to --
Let's see you follow this.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Here he is, Jerry Seinfeld.
-All right. So,
one of the things that's
different about being a kid
is kids don't want
other kids to wait.
They want them to wait up.
"Would you wait up?"
Everything with kids is "up."
Wait up. Hold up. Shut up.
Mama, clean up.
Just let me stay up!
With parents, it's the opposite.
Everything is down.
Calm down.
Slow down. Come down here.
Sit down. Put that down!
All right. You're grounded,
and keep it down in there!
♪♪
-Oh, that's good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is almost a perfect
Seinfeld impersonation.
-Thank you.
-That is a good bit.
-Yeah.
-I like that bit.
My turn. Let's start
the Stand-Up Generator
of Jerry Seinfeld's bits.
[ Beeping ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Star Wars."
-Interesting. "Star Wars."
This is your take
on "Star Wars."
-This is a little bit I have
This was a bit --
It was a pretty good bit.
It didn't quite
make it into my set,
but I always liked it,
thought it was funny.
-Okay, I'm going to do it
right now.
Here we go. It's on cue cards.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Jerry ] Thank you
very much. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Okay, people.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I watch a lot of "Star Wars"
with my kids.
Don't care for it personally.
I can say that publicly,
because they were never going
to put me in "Star Wars" anyway.
I'm wrong for the tone.
You don't want a character
in "Star Wars"
that says things like,
"You know..."
[ Laughter ]
I don't think we need
all the back-flipping
in the lightsaber duels.
Not really a very effective
combat technique.
Doesn't hurt your opponent
in any way.
The cartwheels, splits,
the hand-springs,
no one is scared of someone
that can do these things.
And if you want to go
to a different platform,
just step down to it.
Someone's trying to kill you!
You need to focus!
People!
♪♪
Step down to the platform!
-That was really good.
-[ Normal voice ]
That's not bad?
Not bad? I had to do --
I did the high voice at the end.
-Yeah, the exasperated --
-Yeah, exasperated --
[ As Jerry ]
Get to the platform!
You focus!
[ Stammering indistinctly ]
flipping with the thing!
[ Normal voice ] Okay.
-All right.
-Here we go. Jerry,
let's start the generator here.
[ Beeping ]
-"Pizza Hut."
-"Pizza Hut." All right.
Oh, this is good.
This is a --
♪♪
-Pizza.
-Okay. So,
Thanksgiving is over now.
We've all eaten a lot.
Feeling a little full.
Feeling a little heavy.
We all want to lose weight.
Every person in America
would like to lose
a little bit of weight.
Not one person
has ever lost 1 ounce ever.
Do you think a possible
explanation might be
that we are still trying
to figure out more ways
to get cheese
into a piece of pizza?
Okay?
We're hollowing out the crust.
We're injection-molding
that with cheese.
Now they're double-layering
the foundation
with another layer of cheese
beneath the main layer.
The whole god-damn thing is
cheese to begin with, folks!
It's pizza!
Now, I hear Pizza Hut
is coming out with a new thing.
They will actually
bake your head
right into a block of cheese.
There's no pizza.
It's just cheese coming in
every orifice of your skull.
Maybe that will be
enough cheese for us.
-That's beautiful.
♪♪
You put a little Seinfeld
spin on that.
Even saying the word "pizza"
is not how you say pizza.
-No?
-No, you said "paetza."
Which is not how you say pizza.
That's funny. All right.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see what's up next.
Here we go. Start it up.
[ Beeping ]
"Rubber dividers"?
-Oh, the rubber dividers
in the supermarket.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-I like this bit. Okay.
-All right, rubber divider,
I know that.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As Jerry ]
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Okay, people.
[ Laughter ]
I like those little
rubber dividers.
[ Normal voice ]
Sorry. I'm just --
-You got to pace it up.
Pace it up.
-I'm reading off the cue cards,
so I'm just trying to make sure
I get the --
[ As Jerry ] I like -- I like
those little rubber dividers
they give you
at the supermarket checkout,
because you want your items,
and you want a little
property there, too.
-Yeah.
-Like a little rubber fence.
You don't want
other people's items
fraternizing with your items.
Could be a bad influence.
Now, there are two ways
to use a rubber divider.
You can either put it down
on the conveyor belt
like most people do.
Sometimes I just hold it
in my hand.
"Hey, your potato chips...
kind of creeping up on my box
of doughnuts there, pal.
[ Laughter ]
May want to back it off
a little, okay?
A little too close for comfort!
Huh? You listening to me?
Are you listening to me?"
You need to police those
checkout lines sometimes.
"Hey! 13 items there, buddy boy.
Come over, count them up.
Read the sign.
Hit the road, there. Hey!
I said move it. Come on, go, go!
13 items or less."
♪♪
-You're keeping up.
You are keeping up.
-[ Normal voice ]
I'm keeping up?
-Yeah, I think it's a tie
at this point.
-I think -- I would love --
Maybe I should go on tour
as Seinfeld 2,
and I'll just do
all your material,
and then we could go both
go on tour at the same time.
-Yeah.
-Or maybe --
Oh, I got a great idea.
Why don't --
This is actually an idea.
Why don't we do a big concert
where different comedians
come out,
and they do 10 minutes of their
favorite comedian's bits?
So you come out and do 10
minutes of favorite bits,
and then all goes --
it all goes to charity.
-Yeah. Well, it'd have
to go to charity,
'cause that's going to be
a horrible show.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
-Well, you thought about it.
[ Laughter ]
Why don't you bring it home
with one last set?
Start the generator! Here we go.
-Okay, last bit.
-Last bit!
[ Beeping ]
-"Birthday clown," okay.
-Oh, "birthday clown." Okay.
-"Oh, 'birthday clown.'"
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
"Oh, 'birthday clown.'"
[ Laughs ]
-What? What's funny about that?
-It just makes me laugh.
You go, "Oh, 'birthday clown.'"
-Well, so, you know,
I have kids now,
so I got to go to these -- a lot
of kids' birthday parties.
I used to, anyway.
And I don't really like them.
I don't like -- The birthday
party clown always corners me
and wants some advice
on his comedy career.
[ Laughter ]
And I don't know what
to tell him.
He says, you know, how could
I help him get his own TV show.
I go, "Dude, I just went
from having my own show
to these parties myself.
I don't know
how to do it in reverse."
-That's exactly
a perfect Seinfeld.
That is a perfect --
That's a perfect Seinfeld.
It's official!
Jerry Seinfeld
is the better Jerry Seinfeld
and the winner of our first-ever
"Tonight Show" Stand-Up Battle.
Thank you, my friend.